il balade insouciante dehors tatiana ne
l'avait pas vécu depuis longtemps avec
ses quatre enfants il a quitté la ville
de vous tient à une trentaine de
kilomètres au nord de kiev désormais
réfugié en italie elle est encore
marquée par les souvenirs de la guerre
dans son pays
les combats étaient très forts quand les
bombardements ont commencé chez nous on
entendait en permanence les missiles sur
nos têtes c'est là que je me suis dit
qu'il fallait partir
j'ai mis ce que j'ai pu dans une valise
et je suis parti avec ma mère et mes
enfants
arrivés en italie fin mars sa famille a
été accueillie ici à risque aldina au
nord de milan dans cet appartement saisi
alain grand guetta la mafia calabraise
c'est là que je tort c'est confortable
score et par là on a une grande armoire
pour ranger nos services
ce logement fait partie des 3250 biens
confisqués à la criminalité organisée en
lombardie et il n'est pas le seul de la
zone à être mis à disposition des
réfugiés dans cet immeuble de la commune
voisine un autre appartement s'apprête à
accueillir une famille ukrainienne
fraîchement arrivé en italie à théza on
attend que la préfecture communiquent
l'identité des personnes qui seront
accueillis ici on est en train de finir
les derniers préparatifs car le logement
vient d'être rénové il a été mis à
disposition de la commune l'année
dernière ça tu concernés a été accro
monétique
l'état italien dispose de près de 40000
biens saisis à la mafia un patrimoine
qui dépasse les 300 millions d'euros
géré par l'agencé nationale des biens
séquestrés
le ministère de l'intérieur nous a
demandé de repérer les logements
disponibles et habitable sur le court
terme par les familles
alors nous avons identifié des biens qui
peuvent être utilisés immédiatement donc
un genre dans un mois ou dans 98 mais
au total 622 habitations ayant appartenu
à des groupes mafieux ont été mises à
disposition des réfugiés ukrainien en
italie